so today I'm going to tell you about
what's called Catalans conjecture so
even though it's called the conjecture
it's actually known so this was proved
by a mathematician about 15 years ago
and it's a question about or a statement
about perfect powers okay so what do I
mean by perfect powers first of all I
mean take some whole number 1 2 3 so on
and raise it to a power which is larger
than 1 okay so squares cubes and so on
so if you start to write these things
down one is a perfect power in fact a
power of itself to any exponent 2 is not
3 is not but then we get 4 which is 2
squared then we have to go up to I guess
8 which is 2 cubed and 9 is 3 squared +
16 25 am I gonna run into any cube soon
let's see Oh 27 and 36 and 49 and so on
so these are numbers that can be built
by taking two integers and raising one
to the power that's exactly right yeah
so of course all we've seen so far
mostly squares and cubes
I guess 16 is also a fourth power but
you can take the exponent to be as large
as you want raise it as high of a power
as you want and you can take the number
to be as large as you want to I'm just
trying to put them in order so do these
numbers become more common or less
common as we go down the number line so
they become less common and generally
you think they're spread out right like
just think about squares for example if
you hand me a big number like a million
and you want to know about how many
squares are less than a million well
it's about square root of a million
right because that's how small the
number has to be to be less than a
million after you square it
they're cool numbers they're kind of
spread out as you go along and get
bigger and bigger but notice that in the
beginning here some of them are close
together so we've got actually a pair of
consecutive powers so separated only by
one I guess here we have separated by
two and three and four and so on so
there's some separation here but what
kadhalan conjectured and this is a
question people have been interested in
for hundreds of years actually is this
particular pair of eight and nine so the
fact that three squared minus two cubed
is equal to one or it really that you
have any two powers which differ by one
no other example of that was known and
so what kadhalan conjectured is
this is the only time that this happens
that you have two powers whose
difference is exactly one but it was
unknown if like a gajillion and four
yeah that's exactly right that's oh we
didn't know for a long time
whether or not this conjecture was true
so back a few decades ago we did know
that if it wasn't true there would be
only finitely many exceptions so this
tends to be easier to show in general
right that okay I know that there's a
really large number of things happening
or only finitely many times it happens
but to show that there's only one is
what we didn't know until recently so
it's known yes so this is what was
proved by this mathematician me he'll
ask you in fact these are the only
consecutive perfect powers okay so this
notion that okay they probably kind of
spread out as time goes on is it least
true if spreading out means bigger than
one I mean the proof of this is really
advanced and so okay we don't have time
for I don't know the next couple of
years to go through it but I want to
tell you at least about sort of a
special case of this and something
that's been known for a while but it
gives you an idea of kind of the type of
manipulation you can do to understand
this kind of problem
all right so solving this equation
showing that there's only one solution
and that's it it's pretty hard but let
me show you a special case let's look at
the case of x squared minus y cubed
equals one so for example that has some
solution we know because we have these
consecutive powers so we're really just
asking about a squared differing from a
cube by one okay so why doesn't this
have any other solutions well here's
what you want to do general rule adding
and understanding factors at the same
time is hard that's why for modulus
theorem is hard that's why this kind of
question is hard so let's change it to a
question about multiplication all right
so how do we do that let's move things
to the other side so let's say instead
we're gonna solve this equation now why
have I just made my life better the
reason why is because this thing breaks
up into two factors anytime you see a
difference of squares like this you can
factorize it in this way and so this
just changes from a very hard problem
about addition and multiplication
interacting together to just
multiplication okay
so now why is this better why do I find
out whether or not this has solutions
here's the idea the factors of why any
number that divides why has gotta divide
one of these two things and so let's
ignore two for the moment let's pretend
that Y is odd so two doesn't divide Y so
if Y is odd that means then that any
factor of y has to divide one of these
two things but it can't divide both of
them at once and the reason why is that
whatever these two numbers are they
differ only by two so for the same
reason they can't have a common factor
other than possibly two so if Y is odd
all the factors of Y either divide X
minus one or a factor of Y divides X
plus one but not both at the same time
which means that both of these numbers
have to be cubes so these are both cubes
because any number which divides Y we
know there's at least three copies of
but all of those copies have to go to
the same one of these two numbers and so
we've got two cubes which are only two
apart
right so the difference between these
two cubes is only two but that never
happens with cubes right because we know
what the cubes are 1 8 27 and so on and
that for sure spreads out as you go
along and so you can't have any cubes
which are separated by two and so you
can't have any solution to this equation
at least if Y is odd well then it's a
little bit harder but not that much no
so in general of course the proof is not
via this plan although changing from
addition to multiplication is the
important part of the proof actually and
important part of the proof but this is
just sort of the smallest tiniest piece
the step in the right direction towards
proving this kind of thing everyone
thanks for watching this video I'm just
working on brilliants problem of the
week which triangle has the greatest
area I can't decide if this is a trick
question or
do they have the same area let me get 4c
ah it says it's okay I got it wrong but
it says here and this is true getting
stumped is part of learning and now we
get to continue and discuss the
solutions yeah see I probably should
have done better working out like that
person did but you know we're recording
here in a hurry now
brilliant dog is a fantastic
problem-solving website it's also the
sponsor of today's video in case you
hadn't noticed and the thing I like
about brilliant is it's full of all
sorts of quizzes and courses and curated
lessons that doesn't just tell you stuff
so that you'll know it it helps you
understand that it helps you go deeper
and I think that's a really important
thing you can watch loads of videos and
learn lots of new things but to really
understand that sometimes you actually
have to do the problems have someone
hold your hand as you go through it and
that's what's great about brilliant they
obviously cover loads of mathematics
they also cover science they also cover
computer science there's physics there's
all sorts of things here you really
should have a look by the way if you
enjoyed today's video with Holly I'm
told the open problems group here on
brilliant could also be a great place
for you to be hanging out so what are
you going to have a look at that I'll
include a link down in the video
description now while I get back into
these triangles and figure things out
what you should do is go to brilliant
org slash numberphile you can sign up to
brilliant for free but if you use the
slash numberphile I just mentioned and
there'll be a link in the description
you'll also get 20% off a premium
membership
go and have a look and don't just get
told stuff understand stuff there is a
difference